IS EVERYBODY STAYING THE
CHANNEL.
SHOUT THE MUSIC.
[LAUGHTER]
2020 DEMOCRATIC FIELD LEANING
EVEN FURTHER LEFT WITH OUTSPOKEN
TRUMP CRITIC CONGRESSMAN
ERIC SWALWELL JUMPING INTO THE
RACE.
BASICALLY EVERY DEMOCRAT TRYING
TO TAKE ON TRUMP IS PUSHING
RADICAL SOCIALIST POLICIES WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME ATTACKING
CAPITALISM.
>> THE ONLY WAY TO MEET SOME OF
THESE HISTORIC CHALLENGES IS TO
BE ABLE TO USE THE ENGINE OF
CAPITALISM.
HAVING SAID THAT, IT IS CLEARLY
AN IMPERFECT, UNFAIR, UNJUST,
AND RACIST CAPITALIST ECONOMY.
>> WE ARE GOING TO TRANSFORM
THIS ECONOMY AND THIS GOVERNMENT
AND CREATE A SYSTEM THAT WORKS
FOR ALL OF US, NOT JUST THE 1%.
>> I BELIEVE IN CAPITALISM.
I SEE THE WEALTH THAT CAN BE
PRODUCED, BUT LET'S BE REALLY
CLEAR.
CAPITALISM WITHOUT RULES IS
THEFT.
>> Jesse: FORMER STARBUCKS CEO
HOWARD SCHULTZ IS CALLING OUT
THESE 2020 LIBERAL CONTENDERS.
>> ALL THESE POLITICIANS WHO ARE
CRYING ABOUT CAPITALISM, HAVE
THEY EVER MADE A PAYROLL?
HAVE THEY EVER WORKED IN A
BUSINESS?
WHAT HAVE THEY DONE OTHER THAN
CRITICIZE THE SYSTEM?
WE DO HAVE A SMALL CRISIS OF
CAPITALISM AND WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT IS THE RULES OF ENGAGEMENT
FOR A COMPANY TODAY, GIVEN THE
FACT OF THE GOVERNMENT CAN'T
SOLVE ALL THESE PROBLEMS,
BUSINESSES AND BUSINESS LEADERS
MUST DO MORE FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES
IN THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
>> Jesse: WE ARE LEARNING
BERNIE SANDERS SAYS HE'S GOING
TO RELATE HIS -- RELEASE HIS TAX
RETURNS BY MONDAY.
DOWNPLAYING THE FACT THAT HE'S A
MILLIONAIRE.
STIR GUTFELD, BERNIE IS A
>> Greg: WHO WOULD'VE THOUGHT.
I'M GLAD HE'S A MILLIONAIRE.
EVERYONE SHOULD DO THE BEST THEY
CAN.
THE PLATFORM YOU RUN ON SHOULD
BE ABOUT MAKING A GREAT SYSTEM
GREATER, NOT DESTROYING THE
GREATEST SYSTEM THAT'S EVER BEEN
CREATED.
THEY TALK ABOUT INEQUALITY.
CAPITALISM HAS DONE MORE ABOUT
INEQUALITY THAN ANYTHING.
IF YOU LOOK IN HISTORY,
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN UNEQUAL.
AT LEAST CAPITALISM GIVES YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FROM
STATIC INCOME BRACKETS.
I HAVE MOVED IN EVERY INCOME
BRACKET FROM NOTHING TO
SOMETHING AND BACK AGAIN.
ON MOST ALL INEQUALITY CAN BE
EXPLAINED NOT BY RACE BUT BY
AGE.
THE MEDIAN AGE FOR
JAPANESE-AMERICANS IS DECADES
HIGHER THAN HISPANICS.
SO THEY WOULD HAVE AN HIGHER
INCOME THAN HISPANICS BECAUSE
THEY ARE 20 YEARS ON AVERAGE
OLDER.
ONCE YOU START LOOKING AT THESE
INEQUALITY ARGUMENTS, THEY KIND
OF FALL APART.
YOU SHOULD BE EMBRACING
CAPITALISM AND FREE MARKETS
BECAUSE IT MAKES THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE.
STOP COMPLAINING, YOU BABIES.
>> Jesse: INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW SOMEONE HOWARD SCHULTZ
RUNNING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
FULL-FLEDGED CAPITALIST.
>> Dana: HE IS FRUSTRATED.
HE IS THE LARGEST JOB GENERATOR
OF HIS GENERATION AND REMEMBER
WHEN HE CAME AND DID THE FIRST
INTERVIEW ON FOX, HE SAID LIZ
WARREN HAD COME TO HIM ASKING
FOR A DONATION THAT HE HAD
DENIED HER THAT.
ALSO I CAN TELL YOU EXACTLY WHEN
BERNIE SANDERS IS GOING TO
RELEASE HIS TAX RETURNS.
>> Jesse: WHEN THE BARR REPORT
COMES OUT?
>> Dana: EXACTLY.
HIS PRESS OFFICE IS GOING TO SAY
SEND OUT THE TAX RETURNS.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHY YOU WERE
A PRESS SECRETARY.
YOU UNDERSTAND THE TIMING.
DAGEN, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Dagen: IF YOU GO THROUGH
EVERYTHING THESE MAJOR
CANDIDATES HAVE TALKED ABOUT, IT
IS LIKE A HUNK'S
FLYBACK IT'S
FULL ON SOVIET UNION WEALTH
CONFISCATION.
TOTALLY COMMUNIST.
WERE GOING TO COME AND TAKE YOUR
MONEY.
BERNIE SANDERS, GET RID OF
PRIVATE INSURANCE.
I GUESS HE'S GOING TO HAVE AN
ADDENDUM TO THE PLAN.
HE'S TELLING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WERE GOING TO KICK PEOPLE OFF
THEIR PRIVATE INSURANCE AND THEN
BERNIE AND LIZ AND KAMALA AND
CORY BOOKER GET TO DECIDE WHAT
KIND OF HEALTH CARE YOU GET.
ERIC SWALWELL WENT DOWN THE
LIST, THE KEN DOLL OF THE BUNCH.
HE IS GOING FOR GUN RIGHTS.
GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
>> Greg: WE HAVE ALREADY
FORGOTTEN ABOUT BETO.
HE FADED FASTER THAN...
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: THOSE DON'T FADE.
THEY WILL KILL YOU.
JUAN, ALL THE DEMOCRATS HAD TO
DO.
THE NORMAL NOT GO CRAZY.
THEY CAN'T HELP THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE GOING CRAZY.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK SO AT
ALL.
MOST AMERICANS THINK WE HAVE
INCOME INEQUALITY.
HOWARD SCHULTZ, GOODNESS
GRACIOUS.
HE IS SO IRRELEVANT TO THE WHOLE
CONVERSATION EXCEPT WHEN IT
SERVES YOUR PURPOSE.
HE'S NOT EVEN RUNNING AS A
DEMOCRAT.
>> Jesse: INDEPENDENT.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHAT HE SAYS
NOW AND GUESS WHAT.
HOWARD SCHULTZ, THE ONLY PERSON
HE SERVES RIGHT NOW -- THE ONLY
PURPOSE HE SERVES IS TO TRY TO
GET TRUMP REELECTED, DIVIDE UP
SUPPORT FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> Dana: SAYS HE WILL ONLY RUN
IF THE DEMOCRATS ELECTS A MONTH
SO FAR LEFT.
>> Juan: I DON'T GET IT.
THE SECOND PERSON IS -- THING IS
ABOUT CAPITALISM.
IT'S VERY AMERICAN.
I'M CAPITALIST.
THERE ARE RULES AND RULES ARE
VERY AMERICAN.
LIKE SECURITIES AND EXCHANGE
COMMISSION.
DO YOU BELIEVE IN THAT?
>> Dana: WE HAVE ONE.
>> Jesse: THEY INSTITUTED IT
DECADES AGO.
>> Juan: RIGHT.
THEY PUT LIMITS ON CAPITALIST
BEHAVIOR, WE HAVE A FEDERAL
RESERVE THAT HANDLES INTEREST
RATES.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS 100 YEARS
AGO.
>> Juan: THESE ARE LIMITS.
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
ELIZABETH WARREN, THAT'S GOTTEN
A LOT OF ATTENTION.
>> Dana: IS ANYONE SAYING THEY
ARE GOING TO TAKE THOSE AWAY?
>> Juan: WE DON'T HAVE
UNFETTERED CAPITALISM THAT YOU
WANT TO CELEBRATE.
THERE ARE LIMITS AND WE BELIEVE
IN RULES AND LIMITS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DESTROY
CAPITALISM.
THEY WALKED CAPITALISM THAT
SERVES THE PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: TAKING AWAY EVERY
AMERICANS PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE IS NOT A RULE.
>> Juan: GET OUT OF HERE.
SOCIAL SECURITY?
SUDDENLY THAT IS SOCIALISM?
>> Greg: IT IS OUR MONEY.
>> Dagen: CAN I SAY
BERNIE SANDERS' POLITICAL
DIRECTOR WHO SPENT PART OF HER
CHILDHOOD AND VENEZUELA TOLD THE
ATLANTIC IT WAS BETTER TO LIVE